Польща шокована. Жителі Гданська приносять квіти і запалюють свічки,
щоб вшанувати пам'ять міського голови Павла Адамовича.
Незважаючи на багатогодинну операцію і підтримку сотні поляків,
які прийшли здати кров, мер помер від ножових поранень.
Багато людей у місті знали його особисто.
Для мене це жахлива новина.
Тим більше, що ми разом ходили до школи, ось там.
Я думав, що він виживе.
Я просто фізично спустошена.
Мені дуже сумно, бо я бачила мера дуже часто.
53-річний Адамович понад двадцять років був мером.
У провладних ЗМІ його часто цькували за надто ліберальні погляди.
Міський голова був в опозиції до влади і правлячої партії "Право і справедливість".
Убивство Павла Адамовича, на думку оглядачів,
ще більше розділить Польщу на правих консерваторів і тих,
хто виступає за ліберальні цінності.
Він був одним з облич опозиції у Польщі
проти законів правлячої партії "Право і справедливість",
захищаючи суди, а також, приміром, музей Другої світової війни.
Він став одним з найбільш упізнаваних особистостей
у польській політиці з 2015 року.
Польські громадські рухи закликали людей вийти на вулиці
на марші проти насильства і ненависті. Але президент Польщі Анджей Дуда
вирішив не організовувати марші,  щоб поважати, за його словами,
побажання родини вбитого мера.
Якщо громадяни хочуть організувати марші, спонтанні марші,
то, будь ласка, можуть це робити. Це завжди ознака солідарності.
Але оскільки сім'я хоче, щоб було якомога менше політики в усьому цьому,
ми вирішили, що не будемо організовувати жодного маршу.
Поки що невідомо, чи пов’язаний вбивця з якимись політичними рухами.
За декілька хвилин до нападу Павел Адамович проводив благодійну акцію,
щоб зібрати кошти для дітей, які потребують допомоги.
Мер був на сцені перед тисячами людей, коли нападник кинувся на нього з ножем.
27-річний житель Гданська раніше був засуджений
за пограбування банку, провів у в'язниці понад п'ять років.
Навіть якщо це вбивство і не мало політичних мотивів,
агибель відомого опозиційного політика, на думку експертів,
ще більше поглибить розкол у польському суспільстві,
особливо перед парламентськими виборами, які мають відбутися восени цього року.